early morning in the north
of the netherlands and the fishing boats
are back in port
these are crates of dover soul taken
from the north sea
some of it caught in british coastal
waters
now at the moment that sort of access is
embedded in european law
but what happens after brexit is a lot
more
murky britain wants more control
over its bountiful fishing grounds the
european union wants to keep things
as they are and here in the netherlands
they feel caught in the middle
what we do a lot of red ships you see
them here
are going to the port here on nerdfish
and with different
uh rules there i don't know i'm very
nervous
what's about to happen the eu wants a
long-term deal the uk is suggesting
fresh talks every year
it's deadlock for the anxiety among
these
dutch fishermen there is another country
where fishing is even
higher up the political agenda and that
is france maloyne is france's biggest
fishing port
a place where the sea surrounds you
guyton has spent her life fishing here
he now fears for the future
he says french fishermen will accept the
rules if they're banned from british
waters
but says they dread the consequences
[Music]
of
now the curiosity here is that compared
with financial services or
car manufacturing fishing is a tiny
industry and yet it does have the
potential
to stymie an enormous economic deal and
why
well because fishing isn't really about
economics it's about
symbolism and politics and that idea
of sovereignty it is a word that
resonates with british voters but also
echoes here in france
if the uk won't relent on fishing rights
sources claim french president emmanuel
macron would be ready to veto
a brexit deal
and macron won't be the only one under
pressure spanish fishermen are also used
to taking catches from british waters
the leader of one of their biggest
unions told me he would expect his
government to block any deal
that curtailed that access
brexit fishing talks have often looked
like a lot of effort to go
nowhere but now the pressure is on
everyone says they want a deal
someone will have to compromise to
actually get it adam parsons sky news
belong